desde el juego de campeonato de camino
al supertazón hemos escuchado hablar
mucho sobre balones desinflados en
particular el grado en el cual un balón
de fútbol americano pierde su presión a
qué grado se desinfla con base en
diferenciales de temperatura desde
cuando se infló hasta cuando se usó para
jugar especialmente si fue inflado en un
ambiente tibio y en interiores y se
juega en un clima frío y al aire libre
para pensar en esto tomemos una de mis
ecuaciones favoritas la ley del gas
ideal la cual nos dice que la presión p
multiplicada por el volumen b es igual
al número de moléculas de nuestro gas
ideal en que se mide en términos de
moles multiplicado por la constante r de
nuestro gas ideal multiplicado a su vez
por la temperatura t
podemos acomodar los términos ya que
quiero dejar todo en términos de p
dividimos ambos lados de la ecuación
entre b y nos queda de igual a n por ere
por t entre b ahora veamos el caso
específico del balón de nueva inglaterra
su argumento de él porque pudo
desinflarse naturalmente y que esto no
implique trampa
y su argumento es que pudo haberse
inflado en un lugar cerrado
donde la temperatura aproximada es de 75
grados fahrenheit aproximadamente 24
grados celsius y para aplicar la ley del
gas ideal tenemos que convertirlo a
kelvin por lo que es aproximadamente 297
kelvin esta es la temperatura en un
lugar cerrado fue inflado aquí y luego
pues jugamos afuera
jugamos afuera
donde la temperatura es de
aproximadamente 50 grados fahrenheit por
lo que leí esa fue la temperatura
durante el partido de nueva inglaterra
que es aproximadamente 10 grados celsius
el cual a su vez es aproximadamente 283
kelvin el argumento es que tenemos esta
caída de temperatura podría esta caída
de temperatura con un porcentaje se es
responsable de la pérdida de presión que
se midió en el balón la baja de presión
mano métrica que se midió y eso es
importante porque es algo que se
mencionó mucho en el análisis inicial la
presión mano métrica en el lugar cerrado
donde se infló el balón fue de 12.5
libras por pulgada cuadrada cuya unidad
en el sistema inglés se escribe psi y la
presión mano métrica en el exterior
donde se sintió que el balón estaba
desinflado edad de 10.6
este y para ver si estos números son
consistentes entre sí y que no hubo
trampa simplificamos nuestra ecuación
del gas ideal y hagamos la particular
para esta circunstancia suponiendo que
no hubo trampa es decir que no se dejó
salir o entrar aire al balón pues no
habría cambio en el número de moléculas
la constante de gas ideal obviamente no
va a cambiar porque es la constante
universal del gas así que es constante
en cuanto al volumen supongamos que el
balón está hecho de cuero que es algo
rígido por lo que el volumen podría
cambiar un poquito pero digamos que
mantiene su forma por lo que el volumen
no cambia y queda constante así que
pasamos de estar adentro a estar afuera
para simplificar esto digamos que todo
lo que puse aquí en verde se llama k n
multiplica a r y se divide entre b esto
es igual a una constante que llamamos k
simplificamos esto y queda p la presión
es igual a una constante k no explicada
por la temperatura
recuerden que suponemos que n es
constante porque no entra ni sale aire
si lo vemos de esta manera cualquier
cambio porcentual en la temperatura
tendrá el mismo cambio porcentual en la
expresión
veamos si el porcentaje en el cambio es
consistente con el cambio de presión que
se observa la temperatura tenemos que
manejarla en kelvin el cambio que nos
interesa es de 297 a 283 cuál es la
caída aquí 14 kelvin es la diferencia
sacamos la calculadora 14 kelvin y
comenzamos en 297 así que se divide
entre 297 lo que nos da un porcentaje
aproximado de 5% de caída
así que es una caída del 5% ahora veamos
el porcentaje de caída de la presión
12.5 a 10.6 nos da una diferencia de 1.9
ps o libras por pulgada cuadrada 1.9
dividido entre nuestro inicio 12.5 nos
da un 15.2 por ciento de caída en la
presión lo cual no es consistente con la
caída en la temperatura al inicio de los
análisis vieron estoy dijeron que había
algo muy raro por esta diferencia ya que
por sí sola el cambio de temperatura no
podría ocasionar esta caída en la
presión pero hubo un error en este
análisis inicial pues la presión mano
métrica inicial de 12.5 psi no es la
presión absoluta la presión malo métrica
mide cuanta más presión hay dentro que
afuera hay presión afuera del balón
presiones atmosféricas están
que pueden cambiar según el clima esta
presión es ocasionada por el peso de la
atmósfera así que para calcular la
presión absoluta y el porcentaje
correcto de cambio se tiene que sumar
cuánta presión hay dentro del balón a la
presión que hay fue desconozco las
mediciones de ese día en nueva
inglaterra pero la presión estándar es
de 14.72 psi así que sumamos esto más
14.736 que nos da
un 27.2 psi y si sumamos el 14.7 aquí
tendremos la verdadera presión absoluta
ahora nos quedan 25.3 psi
ahora si podemos calcular el porcentaje
de caída real y compararlo con el 5% de
caída de temperatura seguimos teniendo
la misma caída de 1.9 psi pero va a
estar dividida entre una base más grande
por lo que debemos tener un porcentaje
más pequeño vamos a calcularlo 1.9 /
27.2 nos da un porcentaje algo menor al
7% de caída entonces es aproximadamente
7 por ciento de caída
estas dos cosas no son iguales pero
están cercanas quizá hubieron otros
factores quizá algunas de las mediciones
no fueron exactas quizá la presión
ambiental fue diferente a dentro y
afuera y está la posibilidad
especialmente cuando estamos en el
exterior de que haya algo de humedad en
el balón y esa humedad se evapore
enfriando más el balón lo que podría
hacer que la presión bajará aún más así
que esto no es definitivo pero al menos
los números aquí se aplicaron bien a la
ley del gas ideal y justifican mejor la
caída de presión así que bueno no nos
enredemos con las teorías conspiratorias